let's talk about these French onion
chicken thighs that's perfect for a
weeknight dinner Valentine's night in or
if you want to impress your guests it
starts by Browning seasoned chicken
thighs then putting that to the side
while you slowly caramelize the onions
in olive oil and butter once deeply
Brown add thyme garlic and some white
wine reduce that then add flour which
will thicken up the sauce a bit you'll
then add some Dijon Worcestershire sauce
and beef stock bay leaf and stir until
thicken return the chicken thighs and
its juices back to the skillet bake for
about 20 minutes then top with gruyere
and comte cheese then serve with rice
crusty bread or mashed potatoes enjoy